[Music]
the Victoria's Secret Fashion Show airs
November the 28th on CBS and only we are
with veteran angel Adriana Lima as she
preps to spread her wings once again I'm
still nervous every time Adriana's
gearing up for her 18th show her first
was back in 1999 as a fresh-faced 17
year old whom we met backstage I feel
little nervous but I can wait to Vegas
remember our two girls arriving Tyra
Banks Heidi Klum Lee Stephanie Samer and
I kept looking I'm like oh my god I
cannot believe I'm next to these girls
here it was like a dream
this year's runway will be in Shanghai
China so how's the Adriana prepping well
she's working out and watching her diet
right now again vegetarian but the 36
year old Brazilian bombshell isn't all
work and no play just asked her kids
eight-year-old valentina and
five-year-old Sienna and one of them
just might be following in mom's
footsteps I think my oldest I think
imagine in a few years from now maybe
they are seated watching her how crazy I
would have so much
[Music]
you